on discute avec la mairesse de rouyn
noranda diane dallaire de cette nouvelle
recommandation bonsoir anne dallaire
bonsoir monsieur boileau directeur
national de la santé publique a bien
pris soin de souligner à plusieurs
reprises que tout ça et si on veut
progressif que c'est une première cible
dans l'éventualité quand on atteigne
quand on ne le sait pas la norme aussi
de 3 nanogrammes par mètre que baroin
est ce que ça vous satisfait est ce que
vous en pensez
en fait c'est une belle avancée est une
étape quand même majeurs une étape
importante vers l'atteinte éventuelle du
3 d'anagrammes alors on savait qu'il
pouvait y avoir des délais ou des cibles
peut-être intermédiaire mais le discours
nous ont quand même rassuré même si on
sait qu'il reste plusieurs étapes parce
que ce qu'on nous dit c'est le 15
nanogrammes les experts de la santé
dns pq on s'essuie nous ont dit que
c'est un seuil sécurité la protection un
bruit de protection solide pour les
jeunes enfants et les femmes enceintes
donc être citoyen clientèles plus
vulnérables au sol
ça nous rassure mais on sait que ce
n'est qu'une étape vers l'atteinte est
aussi à quel point les gens drouin son
antre une bonne partie population est
mobilisée dans ce dossier on a entendu
des commentaires recueillis aujourd'hui
chez vous des gens qui se disent mais on
sent un peu comme des cobayes ballotté
entre un seuil et l'autre et surtout
avec peut-être aussi une absence de
clarté quant aux échéances il n'y a pas
un effort supplémentaire qui peut être
fait là dessus mais en fait en fait
quand jésus c'est une étape important
maintenant c'est sûr nous ce qu'on a
demandé formellement la résolution c'est
que le plan d'action de la fonderie vise
l'atteinte des normes non seulement pour
leur sonic mais pour l'ensemble des
métaux oui le plan local mis en examen
oui le nickel le plomb le cadmium bref
on nous allons voir ce qu'il va y avoir
dépôt du plan d'action de la fonderie
des ateliers des rencontres aussi que
nous aurons avec l'environnement mais
clairement nous allons demander aux
mille environnement que les
recommandations de santé publique qui
était donnée aujourd'hui
fassent partie de l'autorisation
ministérielle
mais c'est sûr et certain qui reste des
étapes au vraiment connaître
effectivement
les sites intermédiaires et les
échéances et parce que il faut c'est la
santé de nos citoyens on le dit plus
début tout se règle rapidement le plus
vite possible il ya urgence
urgence d'agir pas de doute là dessus
dans quelle mesure là ce sont des
recommandations comme vous le dites dans
quelle mesure vous fait confiance dans
cette compagne en glenne corps qui
chapeau donc la fonderie horne dans
quelle mesure ils sont de bonne foi et
dans quelle mesure selon vous
véritablement au fond de vous-même vous
pensez qu'ils peuvent mettre les efforts
nécessaires pour que finalement on
atteigne éventuellement cet objectif
vous savez savez je dis depuis début
la fonderie ce une entreprise importante
wanna die on a toujours dit depuis que
la santé c'est la priorité et c'est là
qu'on est rendus mais ça n'a pas aidé
pendant des décennies il a vous
comprenez que la menace que des certains
cela s'est si bien chef je voudrais que
les récentes données qui nous ont été
présentés
par la santé publique où on parlait
d'incidence du cancer du poumon plus
élevé d'espérance de vie moins élevé que
qu'ailleurs au québec les bébés de petit
pote sa série quand même récemment qu on
a été qu'on nous informer de seuil c'est
là que vraiment peut-être c'est les
demandes se sont accélérées maintenant
on demeure confiant vraiment que des
solutions soient emportés et bee gees
tout à l'heure
d comme utile de l'entreprise qui qui
dit vouloir
présenter un plat d'action
d'importance majeure
investir des sommes qui seront annoncées
là mais si ce qu'on attend aussi le
plein d'actions de l'entreprise
mais je voudrais que on demeure très
vigilant comme je dis aujourd'hui c'est
une belle avancée notable majeur mais
c'est pas terminé reste beaucoup
d'étapes avant l'autorisation
les citoyens'' très certainement seront
vigilants également rappelle que
certains spécialistes tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé dans les années 70 quant à des
risques potentiels nous allons en 2022
avec les soins que l'on connaît merci
beaucoup aux abonnés madame r ça fait
plaisir de soirée